some people see conspiracies everywhere
and in Marvel's secret Invasion it's
Justified these are all the Easter eggs
and references you may have missed in
the mcu's new conspiracy Thriller
the various scraps that Prescott has
collected on his conspiracy board as
seen in the opening moments of secret
Invasion reveal a lot about what these
Scrolls have been up to for instance
Prescott mentions that these Scrolls
were behind five terrorist attacks in
five countries three of which were
Argentina Colombia and the Philippines
the other two can be gleaned from
studying the wall the fourth Target was
an Oktoberfest celebration in Munich the
location of the fifth attack is probably
London as another headline mentions
people injured in a London explosion
business as usual that's precisely what
they want you to think
look closely you'll also spot a CIA
document labeled treadstone operation
with a mug shot of somebody who is
presumably a scroll this might be
alluding to the born identity and its
sequels as operation treadstone is the
name of the Black Ops organization that
trains Jason Bourne to be an assassin
perhaps secret invasion was giving a tip
of the hat to another Espionage Thriller
Nick Fury's grudging Ally Sonia
fallsworth portrayed by Olivia Coleman
is a character created specifically for
the secret Invasion TV series she has
yet to appear in any of the Marvel
Comics but her last name is awfully
familiar Sonia shares a last name with
James Montgomery fallsworth a character
from the comics who takes on the mantle
of the British superhero Union Jack
observant fans will know that James
fallsworth has already appeared in the
MCU as one of the Howling Commandos in
Captain America the First Avenger but
he's never called Union Jack in the film
it's likely that Sonia is meant to be
directly descended from this Ally of
Captain America it's also worth noting
that Joseph Chapman a character in the
comics who later succeeded falseworth as
Union Jack has actually fought Scrolls
before it's possible that elements of
both Chapman and James fallsworth could
be combined to establish a version of
the hero played by Olivia Coleman in the
MCU
anybody watching secret Invasion will
immediately get cold war Vibes because
the show has strong connections to Cold
War Espionage the show's creators wear
their influences on their sleeves
executive producer Jonathan Schwartz has
said that the series was inspired by spy
Thrillers set in the Cold War such as
the novels of John le carre and the TV
series The Americans like in the Cold
War the threat of nuclear war looms over
secret Invasion though there's one thing
that distinguishes it from real life
events during the Cold War there was
always one thing that gave both sides
pause the possibility of mutually
assured destruction which prevented both
world powers from going too far there
are no such assurances here the Scrolls
actually want mutually assured
destruction the humans can blow each
other Sky High for all they care because
the scrolls are unaffected by
radioactivity Marvel fans will spot an
interesting Easter egg in the scene with
popristian during the first episode
you'll notice that Talos uses the same
face that he used in Captain Marvel that
is to say Ben Mendelson's real face and
he even uses the same name
Aidan Keller anything in our foul about
this one having a wife
when Talos infiltrated shield and first
met Fury back in 1995 he used the name
Keller clearly Talos is recycling the
same fake identity the only real
difference is that Talos wore glasses
with his disguise in 1995. it makes
sense that Talos would dig up his old
identity rather than make a new one why
reinvent the wheel this makes it easier
for Talos to remember his fake name and
cover story however much like a person
using the same password for every single
account on every single device Talos may
have gotten careless recycling this
identity is probably a mistake because
popristian eventually sees through the
disguise and recognizes him it seems
like pupper's chin must have worked with
Talos in the past so maybe he finally
remembered where he'd seen that face
before it was probably those glasses
that threw him off but
they do kind of complete the look
if you've been paying attention then
you'll know that some members of the
scroll Council shown in episode 2 have
appeared elsewhere in the series most of
these scroll leaders hold some kind of
important position in human society
whether they're world leaders or
well-known television figures in the
news coverage of the Moscow bombing the
scroll acting as the UK prime minister
can be seen denouncing the attacks
meanwhile Sergio caspani the NATO
Secretary General is a scroll as well as
Chris Stearns a talking head from an
American News Channel the only council
members who don't seem to have
infiltrated major institutions are Jack
hukman and Shirley Sager fans familiar
with the 2008 secret Invasion Comics
will know that the news reports and the
subsequent reveal that these powerful
people are Scrolls parallel a scene from
the comics in secret Invasion number
five there is an entire two-page spread
devoted to showing all of Earth's
leaders on live TV cheerfully announcing
that they have been Scrolls all along
aside from being a unique location for
an interrogation scene The Butchers shop
from episode 2 of secret invasion is
also the source of an Easter egg if you
look closely you will glimpse a logo on
a white coat hanging in the front of the
shop in the stylized shape of a bowl
that same logo is planted on the
background of the previous episode when
Gaia is sneaking around Moscow on her
way to meet up with popristian there is
a refrigerated truck in the background
that Bears this same logo if the entire
butcher's shop is a front for one of
Sony's operations then this would
suggest that Sonia wasn't far behind
when Fury and Talos were tailing Gaia of
course it also seems like Sonia is
running her operation right under the
nose of the owner who seems pretty
surprised when Sonia Waltz is into his
shop despite it being locked either that
or he's simply being paid to let MI6 use
his shop and not ask questions if that's
the case it might just be an astonishing
coincidence that The Butchers were
unloading meat just a few feet away from
a scroll
the sequence that shows Nick Fury and
Bob taking hostages was foreshadowed in
a previous MCU film as Fury and Talos
are sneaking around the house of the
scroll posing as Robert Bob Fairbanks a
message from Talos to Fury via earpiece
signals that something is amiss
sorry new I was busy kicking Bob's ass
at a glance this dialogue sounds
innocent enough but Fury can tell that
something's wrong it turns out that Bob
is holding Talus at gunpoint in an
attempt to lure Fury into a trap but
Fury doesn't fall for it fans who paid
close attention during Captain Marvel
would also know immediately that
something isn't right when Fury meets
Carol Danvers in 1995 he refuses to be
addressed by anything other than his
last name everybody calls me fury not
Nicholas not Joseph not Nick just Fury
if you already know that Fury's first
name is a touchy subject for him then
it's easy to spot Bob's deception from a
mile off unlike Talos Bob hasn't known
Fury for decades so he couldn't possibly
have known that trying to get onto a
first name basis with him is a big No-No
one scene from episode 4 of secret
Invasion shows Talos and Gaia sitting on
a park bench you may have been too
focused on their heartfelt conversation
to notice that the bench is seemingly
meant to be a memorial as it's engraved
with the words Carter
1933-2000. the first name on the
dedication is obscured so we can only
theorize about who it refers to it's
definitely not Peggy Carter if Peggy had
been born in 1933 she would have only
been a child during the events of
Captain America the First Avenger
however it's very possible that Peggy
Carter had a younger sibling in fact the
TV series Agent Carter shows that Peggy
has a brother named Michael of course
Agent Carter is not necessarily Canon
and the dates don't quite add up after
all Michael wouldn't have been old
enough to serve during World War II if
he was born in 1933. regardless Peggy
Carter almost definitely has some kind
of sibling in the MCU even if it's not
Michael in Captain America Civil War
Sharon Carter mentions that Peggy is her
aunt and Van Camp later clarified that
Peggy is technically Sharon's great aunt
that means that Peggy must have had a
sibling who would be Sharon's
grandparent
there's something satisfying about a
little continuity during the tavern
scene in episode 2 Fury gets into a
little scuffle with an unnamed member of
Roadies security detail when the man
tries to grab Fury and escort him out
the door Fury breaks from his grip and
twists the man's arm behind his back
observant fans have pointed out that
this same character appears again in
episode 4 in the scene where Rhodey
greets president ritzen the agent's arm
is in a sling clearly the result of his
highly regrettable encounter with Fury
I'm Nick Fury
even when I'm out
I'm in
many Marvel fans were hoping to see an
Avenger besides Roadie in secret
Invasion it didn't end up happening but
we did get a cameo of an MCU character
you've probably forgotten about we bet
you've never given a second thought
about Rick Mason from Black Widow if you
recall Mason is the guy who Natasha
called when she needed to lie low when
Natasha was on the run in Black Widow he
provided her with a safe house and
multiple fake identities including the
unfortunate moniker of Fannie Longbottom
we suspect that nobody was expecting
Mason to appear in secret Invasion yet
in episode 5 he pokes his head into Nick
Fury's jet tossing Fury a fake ID and
some sassy one-liners
you're welcome a grumpy Fury mentions
that he'd rather be on his Helicarrier
and Mason explains that it's been
mothballed though where a thing like
that would fit feels like a bit of an
open question the last we saw of Fury's
famous helicarriers after Steve Rogers
needed to destroy most of the fleet to
stop Hydra was when Fury brought one out
of storage to help the Avengers in the
Battle of sokovia unfortunately Fury
didn't get to bring out the big guns in
this series but there's always a chance
that we may see them again in the future
in the episode 5 scene at the Finnish
airport secret Invasion introduces us to
a character we've never seen before a
man called Mr caronen the next scene
reveals that kerhonen is actually Fury
in Disguise and he is using a special
technology that we first saw in Captain
America the Winter Soldier Natasha used
the same trick to sneak inside Shield
headquarters it turns out this Tech has
a name the Widow's Veil The Tech also
played a small but pivotal role in
2021's Black Widow and appeared in the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier along with
a few episodes of Agents of Shield of
course the Widow's Veil and secret
invasion is not as sophisticated as what
we saw in Captain America the Winter
Soldier a fact that Sonia gleefully
lampshades a billion dollars of research
and development and all the Widow's Veil
can cloak as your face what about the
rest of you that's the newer version not
this one Fury still needs to wear gloves
just to conceal his hands well when
Natasha used this Tech her holographic
mesh extended to cover her hands despite
its shortcomings The Widow's Veil is
still the closest to Nick Fury will ever
get to having these shape-shifting
abilities of a scroll
when Roadie is urging president ritzen
to plunge the planet into a nuclear war
we are given a brief glimpse of the
bunker that contains the nuclear
warheads it will look awfully familiar
to Marvel fans it's visually very
similar to the bunker where Tony Stark
and Steve Rogers fought at the end of
Captain America Civil War that bunker
didn't originally hold nukes but it's
certainly possible that the former Hydra
bunker could have been rebuilt or
repurposed by the US government in the
intervening time or maybe Marvel Studios
is just reusing a design our bet is that
the parallel was likely intentional on
the showrunner's part as this wasn't the
first time they used a visual reference
to Captain America Civil War the title
cards that appear on the screen in
secret Invasion to introduce new
locations are in the exact same font as
the title cards that appear in Captain
America Civil War clearly the creators
of the show were trying to signal that
secret Invasion falls under the same
genre as civil war relatively grounded
Espionage Thriller and used those nods
to show that the two belong in the same
corner of the MC see you during the
show's climax graphic and Gaia show off
their new powers which come from the DNA
of several different Marvel characters
both use Captain Marvel's abilities to
fly and shoot beams of cosmic energy
throughout the fight Graphics arms
shapeshift into the arms of Korg the
Abomination coal obsidian and Ebony ma
he also flaunts ebony Ma's telekinesis
Powers meanwhile Gaia also borrows the
DNA of Korg and collabsidian and she
flexes a bicep that clearly belongs to
Drax while she's at it she Dodges a car
by phasing out a power she got from
Ghost from Ant-Man and the WASP Gaia
even uses the empath abilities of mantis
sleep
[Music]
several other characters abilities were
not shown in the battle but their DNA
was still clearly part of the Harvest
according to Graphics computer monitor
these include Captain America the Winter
Soldier black panther Thor Groot and so
many more if you examine the list
closely it does raise some questions
about where Fury got some of the DNA
samples Fury explains in episode 5 that
he collected the DNA from the blood
spilled at the Battle of Earth in
Avengers end game some fans have
observed that a couple of the DNA donors
namely Ghost and the Abomination weren't
present at the Battle of Earth so Fury
must have gotten them elsewhere
he is a scroll
the reveal that Roadie was actually a
scroll has huge implications for the MCU
but the biggest question is how long
he's been replaced by one some have
guessed that Roadie was only replaced
after his cameo in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier While others have
speculated that Roadie was a scroll ever
since Iron Man 2. episode 6 of secret
Invasion doesn't provide an exact period
of time it's been held hostage
for a long time
however there are little clues that
allow us to guess when Roadie might have
been replaced by an imposter once Roadie
is released from his pod we see he has
difficulty walking everyone else walks
just fine so it's not something you can
chalk up to numb legs from lying in
their ponds for so long more likely this
suggests that the real Roadie was
present in all the MCU movies up until
Captain America Civil War when he
received his spinal injury in secret
Invasion we see Roadie wearing a
hospital gown which suggests that maybe
he was replaced while he was still
recovering from the Civil War incident
we have no way of knowing for sure at
least until the release of armor Wars
which will presumably fill in what
happened to Rhodey
[Music]
thank you